starting tonight at Jimmy Kimmel's
Comedy Club Las Vegas is getting tricks
and a treat all weekend so let's welcome
former Club DJ very Vegas of you okay on
air personality and comedian tricks to
Las Vegas now as he gets warmed up for
tonight's show it starts at 7 30. yeah
the link will be uh well yeah I think
it's by the link in the Promenade there
this is really cool so how do you get
how do you actually get warmed up for
the show for your shows uh video games
really video games
no everyone thinks I'm crazy I play toon
Dash on my phone and if I don't play
tune Dash on my phone I'm not right
that's interesting what is what is two
dash what is that game it's like a a
ripoff of Candy Crush
you know that's how I get my I try to
tell you in your Zone Nick I want to be
loose I don't I don't like to overthink
shows I don't like to be like you I got
to do this this I like to be mad loose
when I go on stage so yeah video games
well you're I can tell you're loose
already you were on air personality this
is your thing I saw Jolly Ranchers in
the green room I was a happy boy I was a
happy New Year right now let's before we
get to the show specific let's talk
about you where does the word tricks
come from or the name excuse me you know
it's funny I used to be a prankster oh
and uh they wanted to name me Joker I
was I was a prankster I I man I look
back on some of the pranks I shouldn't
be here right now can I can you just
share at least one of your favorites to
look back on in my life okay you know
what well don't judge the PG-13 song
Don't Judge Me okay
we we called a a friend's mom and
convinced her that her son was in jail
we took a little far she was crying oh
no I was a good I was a good officer
told we told her that he was stealing oh
you played the officer yeah he got
caught for stealing socks in the
department store I was convinced it too
and she was just like no how could he do
that and she was cursing him out on the
phone and then I can't when the review
came I'm not going to repeat what she
said today don't do it don't do it just
it's a family show yeah but yeah so they
want to call me Joker but at the time
the Batman movie was coming out so they
just went with tricks instead which I
don't know what's the you know I like it
the Segway but there have been tricks
ever since I love it okay so tricks what
kind of tricks do you have up your
sleeve for your shows oh we're gonna
have fun what's your show like I'm a
very observant comic I didn't pick on
people so listen don't do the whole I
don't want to sit in the front
I don't pick on people at all we have
fun in my show okay okay I don't I don't
segregate anybody you know talk about
stuff that's on your mind but I don't
want to you know I don't bore you with
politics right I don't do any of that
man I Just Want to Have Fun okay make
everyone laugh just Good Vibes just Good
Vibes we're going back to the 80s people
where you can just go into a comedy club
and just laugh yeah you know that's
that's me that's what it's all about now
you you are you're not a local you're
not from Vegas but you do live here I
live here now yeah I live in Vegas so
what does it mean for you to be
performing at Jimmy Kimmel who is a
local oh look I mean it's a dream yeah
performing in Vegas I've always dreamed
about performing here and I remember the
first time I saw myself on a billboard
here I literally weeped wow we were
going up man we were going up the
escalator and my boy goes look up and I
looked up and my face was literally on
this billboard and I just started crying
he made fun of me for about two minutes
but I was like you have no idea you
deserved it because like this dream
thank you everybody Vegas has always
been a dream for me so I'm I'm just
happy to be living it man it's cool well
congratulations you got tonight you got
tomorrow you got some rest of the
weekend two shows Saturday Sunday
tonight whoever's coming tonight Here
for a Good Time okay we're ready good
time we are ready well thank you so much
I like Winnie the Pooh pocket that's
cute
catch tricks at uh the Jimmy Kimmel
Comedy Club at the link Promenade that
is January 5th tonight to the 8th
tickets and more information at
Ticketmaster